I've tried to dip a little bit out of
the resource politics stuff for the last
couple weeks especially the DeSantis
Trump stuff because people don't realize
we are still over six months away from
the first primary we have a debate next
month but the first vote will not even
be cast in Iowa until January of next
year and everyone's fighting and going
crazy so I've been trying to take my
pedal my foot off the pedal at just a
little bit but I thought we'd dive in
just to end Today's Show because I know
you guys we're all sort of roughly on
the same side of this thing maybe with
some differences I thought it'd be
interesting here's more from that daily
wire Place uh former president Donald
Trump retained a large lead in Iowa New
Hampshire and Florida following a boost
in the polls after his indictments
according to the latest Real Clear
Politics polling average Trump's
National polling sits at 52.6 percent
according to the RCP average DeSantis is
in second place with 21 former VP Mike
Pence holds third at 6.3 and Haley and
Scott come in fourth and fifth with 3.5
and 3.3 respectively desantis's polling
average has leveled off around 20
nationally after jumping into the race
in late May
the governor had reached as high as 30
percent in some polls earlier this year
before he officially launched his
campaign Trump's large lead in the polls
comes as he has dominated headlines for
months following his April indictment in
Manhattan on 34 felony counts of
falsifying business records two months
later the former president was indicted
in Miami on 37 felony counts relating to
his handling of classified documents
many Republicans including some of
Trump's opponents of the GOP Primary
have defended the leading candidate
amidst his legal battles calling the
indictment's politically motivated
targeting of President bide Joe Biden's
Chief rival first let me just ask you
guys kind of philosophically Andrew you
first
um taking my foot off the pedal on this
thing and just kind of letting it play
out people know my personal feelings
about this I voted for Trump I like
Trump obviously I think DeSantis is a
better choice at this point do you think
we could all take a breath do you think
that would anyone that's roughly on the
right at this point or might vote for
one of these guys the thing is everyone
just kind of taking a breath might be
good instead of all the infighting of
course you're absolutely right about the
time here that this point in when
Hillary Clinton was running against
Barack Obama she had the basically the
same numbers that Trump has now Trump is
a amazing character he is a great
showman he is great at what he's doing
the Democrats are playing our passions
as if we were a church organ they really
have figured out that rage will will
help them and enrage makes us stupid
rage always makes you stupid so you
indict him unfairly he was indicted
absurdly in New York he was indicted
unfairly in the at the federal level but
because Hillary Clinton did almost
exactly the same thing he did and walked
away scot-free it's infuriating it makes
people want to support him he knows what
he's doing but if you listen to what
he's saying his message is gone his
original attachment to the common sense
solutions that made him actually a good
president for three of his four years uh
is is kind of lost he just was saying
whatever he thinks people want to hear
DeSantis has a better record the santis
is blowing this he is doing a bad job so
even though it's far out he has got to
change his game his people do not know
what they're doing they don't have any
sense of social media they don't have
any they don't have any sense of the
modern media whatsoever he walks around
talking about Florida like Allison
Hannigan talking about band camp in
American Pie you know I mean he just
keeps bringing it up you know that's not
what California cares about it's not
what Iowa cares about that said he's got
a couple of good things his his pack has
a good ground game in Iowa bringing on
you know they're knocking on doors that
always helps but until they let this guy
get out with the people and humanize
them a little bit and let let them see
that he is somebody with a plan he
doesn't have to be a trump showman the
biggest thing he needs and the problem
no one in politics has saw is how to
attack Donald Trump because that's who
he's running against how to attack
Donald Trump without becoming Donald
Trump and that is and that is the thing
he's going to have to figure out before
this gets into the fall and winter but
you are absolutely right Dave this is
too too early to decide where this is
going to go it's not too early for the
Santas to start thinking about what he
needs to do to become a national
candidate
thank you